- I think the fire crotch thing started
way before the Lindsay Lohan time.
Ever since, I guess, I hit puberty.
(techno music)
Hi, my name is AJ, and I'm a redhead.
This week, I'm gonna go blonde.
My color red, I feel like it's slightly
different from the average Irish redhead,
'cause I'm actually not even Irish at all.
And I'm the only one with red hair.
Both of my siblings have dark brown hair,
dark brown eyes, but my mom has red hair.
I feel like I used to
find, "ginger," offensive,
but I actually call myself,
King of the Gingers.
- When I was asked about
dyeing my hair, I said no.
- I personally would never dye my hair.
- I think redheads are unicorns.
It seems like such a cool, unique thing,
that not a lot of people get.
- I've always been nervous about getting
back to the original color, I guess.
Being a redhead is definitely
a huge part of my identity.
- Definitely been told throughout my life
not to ever dye my hair.
- I don't think redheads should
dye their hair any color.
- Every time I go to a hair dresser,
they compliment my red hair.
They try so hard to get
the same exact color,
but they always tell me
how unsuccessful they are.
For my friends who already
know me, it's gonna
come off as a real shock because
they do love my red hair.
I get attention as is with red hair,
but I think going blonde, I'm
gonna get even more attention.
- My name is Yuichi, hairstylist today.
We do the full highlights.
- My feelings towards my red
hair has definitely changed.
In the beginning, I didn't
really think much about it.
As I got into high school, I was
probably the only one with red hair.
I definitely was picked
on for being a redhead.
They would call me
carrot-top, fire crotch,
all of the above.
- And then, we do the permanent
color at the same time.
So we rinse off, check the color.
- I think women with
red hair are glorified
within society, opposed
to men, who are kind of
looked at or have the stereotype
of being nerdy, geeky.
There are a million women leading
actress roles with red hair.
The men red headed roles are always
the best friend or the geek.
Here in L.A., I don't think I really
know of any other redheads.
I haven't dated a redhead before,
but I've definitely
fooled around with one.
Took about two hours
from beginning to end.
Eager to see what I look like.
Oh my God.
(AJ laughs)
Wow.
I look like a completely different person.
I think I'm giving off that,
I don't know, California beach vibe?
I think I look tanner
a little bit, actually.
Looks great.
I do like it, it's definitely different.
It's gonna take a little
bit to get used to.
I think I will be perceived differently
by people who don't know
me, also by my friends, too.
So, now that I'm blonde,
I'm going to live the
rest of the week and see
how everybody reacts to me,
and see if it's any different
from being a ginger.
(steady dance music)
Saw myself, slightly freaked out,
seeing that I didn't know who that was.
I did tell a couple of my co-workers.
They've only known me as a redhead.
We shall see how people react today.
- Oh my God!
- I've had some interesting interactions
with people who had previously known me.
There have been a lot of
Game of Thrones references.
- You look like a Targaryan.
- And Ken doll references as well
from co-workers and clients.
There's also been a lot
of, "You look great,
"except I prefer you as a redhead."
- I believe gingers should
never dye their hair.
Go back, AJ!
- Personally, I almost feel
like I'm wearing a mask,
being blonde because, I've
been red my entire life,
and it's almost like I'm not
even being true to myself.
I slightly miss being a redhead.
I had somebody at the gym
actually comment and say,
I am one of six redheads
that actually come,
and now I'm literally just
like everybody else there.
So something else that I noticed,
is whenever I run into another redhead,
I wait for some sort of acknowledgment.
I was in the grocery store,
probably looked kind of creepy,
staring at this person, still
waiting for some sort of
acknowledgement, or even just eye contact.
I had forgotten that I dyed my hair blond,
and just kind of came
off as a creep, I guess.
So I'm about to call my dad.
- [Dad] Hello?
- Hi, Dad.
- [Dad] AJ!
- You don't like me blonde?
I found myself actually
taking my shirt off
during my workout class today,
which I have never done before.
I walked into work this morning,
and one of my instructors,
first thing that came out of his mouth,
"You look so much more approachable!"
What did I look like when I had red hair?
So as I talk a little bit more
to my friends about being blond,
opposed to being a
redhead, I've noticed that,
although we're thought of as fiery
or temperamental, we're apparently
the least shy of the hair colors,
which I don't know if I
completely agree with that,
because growing up, I
definitely was a lot more shy,
until I got comfortable in my own skin.
Here in Los Angeles, I do
feel that being a redhead,
I stand out a little bit more.
Right now, I kinda feel like I blend
in when I walk down the street.
I don't know if I feel like
I would actually go blonde again.
I mean, I like it, I enjoy it,
but I do feel like this is
hiding my identity a little bit.
Being a ginger is so far into who I am.
I can't see myself going any other way.
Maybe blonde highlights,
every now and then.
(mid-tempo pop music)